I I I'm a pat here and I need to go to
the restroom here's video of three
leftist lunatics and of course they're
masked morons at a coffee at a coffee
shop harassing a Jewish customer who
just wants to go to the bathroom private
property I going to the rest I do need
you to leave I know Israel loves taking
private property and saying it's their
own but we got to head you're not going
to let me go the rest so I need you to
leave I want you to go into the restroom
I need you to leave please I was patn
here and I have a right to go into the
restroom and we have service yeah but I
need to go into the restroom I'm asking
you to leave no you need to let me go
into the restroom I don't I'm asking I
I'm a patn here and I need to go to the
restroom I'm finally asking you to later
no I will not going to leave I'm finally
asking you next so can you please no I
want to go into the restroom that's fine
you can use our restroom we have a
restroom next door no I want to use a a
I want I should not be excluded in other
people they are clear saying no I want
to go into the restroom and what is
standing you're going to be you're not
going to let me into the restroom you
can use our other restroom we have
another rest I want to use this one
you're not they're not letting all you
want to get is a video of saying that an
that Zionism is why you afraid if you
agree with it why are you afraid that
they we take a picture of it oh actually
yeah great if you agree with it why why
are you AF then why you not letting me
in because you're this yeah yeah yeah
yeah history didn't start in 1948
lady free Palestine now please free
Palestine it's always please leave thank
you it's always yeah great we love it
thank you very much uh-huh thank you
thank you very much finally think
how
mentally H I'm sure we got demonetized
already right like you can't say three
times on YouTube what is this look like
these people these mask intersectional
green
haired they've all been fired so
actually there's a nice ending to this
story these people no longer work at
that coffee shop but but imagine
regardless of whatever your feelings are
happening about 10,000 miles away across
the Atlantic in the Middle East that you
would stop a woman from going to the
bathroom who buys a cup of coffee at
your store because of whatever your
feelings about that thing are but that
is how this has
happened
I